Parentheses impact how
we calculate exponents.
Negative four inside parentheses
raised to the second power.
Is not the same thing as a negative
four raised to the second power.
Parentheses tell us about what
the base is in an exponent.
So in the case of negative four in
parentheses raised to the second power
the base is -4 and the exponent
can be expanded to -4 times -4.
-4 squared doesn't have parentheses.
So I take the negative sign in
front of the 4 to mean that I'm
finding the negative of four squared.
The base is four in effect
negative four squared can
be expanded to negative
one times four times four.
Remember that when you see
a negative in front of a base and
there are no parentheses around it you
can just think of it as negative one
times whatever the exponent is.
Evaluate these exponents and be careful
about the sign of your answers.
Enter your answers in the boxes.